ensemble des grands voyageurs des
branches du coït aussi
notre père nous a aimés au delà de ce
que vous pouvez imaginer
qu'est ce que c'est que cette horreur
c'est impossible que je sois là je suis
là sans vraiment être là il ya quelques
années j'ai investi dans une société de
haute technologie qui fabrique d'android
est revenu sur terre pour passer
l'aspirateur chez moi
bon on fait la paix qu'est ce que je
raconte eu pareil gâchis je n'ai que six
jours de batterie et carte et toi de ses
portes je te tue la chaufferie je suis
déjà mort
c'est pas grande sociaux ton père
c'est le propos de ce voyage
[Musique]
la vérité c'est que tu n'as cessé de
vouloir contrôler ma vie j'ai dû partir
vers l'est j'avais pas de nouvelles
j'étais inquiet
jamais été en danger j'ai mis thomas ce
qui est excessif
[Musique]
je crois que thomas ce n'est pas tout à
fait moi
vingt ans ça m'arrivait fonder une
famille le bonheur a besoin de quelques
précisions et de beaucoup d'imagination
ça
sinon l'important si ça va ce que tu
peux le faire
[Musique]
crois qu'un jour ans est souffrir en un
mot les tu as de la chance jamais
je tenais barbare
[Musique]